There was, however, a reason that the panda population ended up as an
endangered species. And that was because their population declined to a
dangerously low number. More pandas were dying each year than being born since
they had lost huge portions of their habitat, making food and mates difficult
to find. Now, even though Gloria's Giant Panda Preserve is doing very well
rehabilitating its population, pandas are actually still endangered worldwide.
Preserves like hers are one of the ways that hopefully pandas will no longer be
endangered anymore someday. Their overall population will one day get to a much
healthier size. Which of these statements I've just written do you think makes
the most sense in terms of the decline of the panda population? A constant
number of pandas died each year. The larger the population, the more pandas
died each year. And the smaller the population the fewer died each year. Or
finally, the larger the population the fewer pandas died each year, and the
smaller the population, the more died each year.